and the notion was we can send a DNA
sequencer smaller than this coffee cup
to Mars or other places and instead of
sending up a $5 billion spaceship to fly
back a sample taken from the subsurface
of Mars we can send a sequencer send the
digital information back and we can
recreate the Martians easily here in a
laboratory my understand is we exchange
about 100 kg of material between Earth
and Mars annually that means when the
oceans existed on Mars and some evidence
as they still do on the sharp surface
that we will either still find living
organisms and they'll very much resemble
what we have here and microbial life and
viral life will in my view be ubiquitous
in the universe